I'm Donna from the red group in Tel Aviv
University I'd like to thank the
organizers for this workshop and this
wonderful opportunity to present our
novel approach our local approach for
answering drug targets using
personalized perspective and using in
silico knock out through ppi networks so
drug target is fair and said an enormous
entrance in computational biology as
drug development is very expensive and
the number of new targets is very large
the applications of any target is very
large so we have kind of a natural and
essential way of computational biology
to step in and our inspiration for the
work
so the inspiration for the work was a
drug target inference used in the
connectivity map project near the
connectivity map project they ranked
small bioactive molecules according to
their ability to reverse the gene
expression signature of a disease so
they took the small molecule and they
compared the gene expression that was
received by introducing the molecule to
the cell and compared it to the gene
expression signature of the disease in
this case you can see that the molecule
upregulated the under activated genes
and down-regulated the over activated
genes and so the molecules are ranked
according to this to their ability to
reverse the gene expression so we looked
on mutations in the prospect of cancer
cell and what we assume is that the
mutation start a signal via the PPI
network and this signal can be viewed
through the differentially expressed
genes in the patient's cell and we all
hypothesize that if we would find drug
targets or nodes in the PPI network that
would reverse the effect of the mutation
on the differentially expressed genes
that would be a very good target for
this patient we will try to find this
drug targets using in silicon knockouts
in the PPI network we start by
simulating the disease state of a
patient we take a PPI network and from
the mutation we propagate through the
network the propagation is a random walk
live restart very similar to the random
walk with restart in half net and we run
it enough time until it saturates so
when we get to this state and we stop
the propagation we have a deterministic
answer to how much signal was received
in each of the nodes in the network and
we now look only on the differentially
expressed genes of the patient
we simulate a drug by by knocking out
its target so by deleting the
corresponding node in the network and
propagating from the mutations again and
again we have a different propagation
and we receive the knockout affected
propagation by simulating this drug and
we do it over and over for every node in
the network's who have many knockout
affected propagations and now we ask
which is the best drug which how should
we rank them so the best drug would be
the drug that would reverse the disease
state propagation to the healthy state a
healthy state is simulated by a network
with no mutations so this network VPI
network with no mutations we choose
random K nodes and we propagate from
this random notes and we repeat it end
time so in our case we found that a
thousand times of repetition kind of
cover give us a good cover of the
network and so by repeating this what we
actually get is a distribution of the
propagation so for each gene a
distribution of how much signal it would
receive through the network through
random activity in the network so for
each gene and each not knock out what we
have is first a distribution of the gym
in a healthy state so how does it behave
in a healthy state in random activity
and the signal in a disease states and
the signal in a knockout state and what
we are actually what we want to check is
whether the knockout helped push the
signal of this gene towards the healthy
state so we actually count in a number
of times here the knockout help pushing
the signal towards the healthy state and
then we average this overall the
differentially expressed genes of the
patient and we get a back to healthy
score for a drug target so this back to
healthy score for the drug target
actually says in average how many times
did this drug help pushing the signal
back to a healthy state we run this on
hippy and network hippy network is a
aggregation of databases of
human ppi networks that gives weighted
network according to confidence of
interactions and we ran this over AML
with 174 patients from cosmic and we
received for each patient a rank drug
target Lists so for each patient the
drug targets that would be best suited
for him now as personal drug targets for
a patient is very scarce and is Vicki
difficult to validate we we had to
aggregate our results
well I will continue expanding in the
mineral so we had to aggregate our
results from different patients to one
full list to compare to known drug
targets the texts
baby
okay so before our small break what we
had is a ranked list of targets for each
patient and now we wanted to check that
against a known list of targets a known
drug targets databases so we had to
aggregate the results from all the
patients and receive one list of drug
targets and we compared it against drug
targets from drag bank and against
causal genes from cosmic and so we see
here our results are predicted dark drug
targets lined up from the best scoring
one to the least scoring one only in the
top one hundred percent nodes in the
network and the blue lights are heats
from cosmic the Green Line our heats
from drug targets so we can see that our
ranked list is very highly enriched in
both drug targets and causal genes and
we wanted to assess whether the
personalized approach that we took
indeed help improve the results so we
built a consensus patient by taking all
common appearing in more than five
patients mutations and differentially
expressed genes and we build this
consensus patient then we ran our
approach on the consensus patient and
then we again lined up our predictions
and as you can see the results are not
significant there underscoring the
utility of using the personalized
approached and we also tried a very
naive approach of discarding the network
just taking the common mutated genes and
see if they are enriched withdrawal
targets and they were not enriched and
it was quite a naive approach of
checking that and we we wanted to assess
still with some kind of personalized
data so for a mutation specific patient
there is some kind of sensitivity
experiments that were done for the
largest group of AML patients the ones
that have the fleet three internal
tandem duplication the word sensitivity
experiments performed
and we took this subgroup and we looked
at the sensitivity of inhibitors in our
networks inhibitors that were
experimentally validated and we saw that
the pi3k received the lowest of the
three back to healthy score in our
predictions and it correspond adore
recap chelated in some way the poorly
responsive to pi3k of the fleet three
itd patients and next in our evaluations
was the mek inhibitor and it corresponds
to the to what the researchers saw when
they try this experimentally the
decreased in proliferation but they
still stable line of apoptosis and
finally the pim inhibitor receive the
highest back to lv score in our
predictions and flip three patients do
respond very nicely 2pm innovator and
that led to the development of a CD 1208
drag now I'm not saying that the
sensitivity this is of course only an
example and it needs to be validated
against a large data set of sensitivity
once a live data set would be available
but it is a nice trend line and what is
also interesting to notice here is the
PM inhibitor so the film inhibitor does
not target only one node it targets tree
no it's been one p2 and p3 and in our
approach it's very straightforward to
simulate a no count of three nodes you
simply knock out the three and run and
run the approach so that's also a very
nice application and with that I would
like to thank you for listening and to
thank or Thailand al a my co-authors
they're here pretending in PSP and were
dead of course and we are all supported
by the saffron foundation
this is
so the nurse nursing the mutation
Heather so if we have other musicians
that are not related to let disease and
this name this drug can close other
dishes that I've been I
is the score sheet so this car is about
reversing the effect on the
differentially expressed genes not the
actual mutations but only the genes that
are affected by the mutations that
mutation yeah and so you are asking if
there is notations that are the
mutations that are not related to the
disease would they yes okay so a great
question would our knockout would cause
any peripheral effect where they change
other nodes in the network that we did
not want to change so it can happen yes
and it's a good question whether to try
and find a knockout that would only
change the differentially expressed
genes and would not shed would not
change the others and that's a question
of I guess how much do we believe to
differentially expressed cut off no we
take some kind of cut off we know that
these genes change their expression but
others might have changed and just
didn't make it to the cutoff and so it's
kind of a softer constraint and saying
change only these expressions and don't
change the others but you could also say
let's take a harder constraint and let's
choose the drug that would only affect
this differentially expressed genes and
we chose not to do it because the cutoff
is kind of focusing us on these genes
but is not so revealing as to other
genes in the network the track targets
of specific
drug targets from dragon Bank are
specific to Emma and uh just 22 drug
targets no drugs oh very close um so I'm
not sure exactly how many drugs was it I
think most drugs had between two to
three targets so I guess so it takes one
propagation takes a few seconds and we
have 15,000 notes in our network so if
you are something that is reasonable and
but no two knockouts would be I mean you
could run it but to knockers three
knockouts as a way of actually exploring
the entire networks becomes too long of
a run and so we only did it with the
specific sensitivity where we knew the
targets and were very ain't so they very
quickly if you also think the question
why do you why we do random why do we do
random worked for diffusions I mean why
do you do to you because we we presume
that the mutation start a signal that
would go through the PPI network and so
the mutation would affect this these
genes that are on the signal I make the
same assumption and I sometimes
questioned the validity of this
assumption myself so except another
point of discussion what do you have to
noon perhaps not this afternoon but
profit one so we do have previous works
on signaling that's what looked at the
shortest path and of course many others
also looked at churches but I'm not
suggesting that shortest path is the
answer I'm saying well we are trying to
model the diffusion process or the
random walk process within a nuclear
slaving but is is a random walk on the
TPI the right way to anyway no I'm not
saying either show the space or random
welcome to think they are various
methods and it's a very good question
what indeed simulate signaling I'm into
effect on the genes how is this
dependent on possible errors that you
could introduce to your ppi because we
know they are definitely not complete
they might have some also some false
positives in there so did you try
introducing like stepwise increasing
noise in these networks and then see how
this changes your results so it's a
great question elevate its corresponds
to what we talked about yesterday
afternoon how much is the network
reliable and what can we do to see
whether it didn't helps us so we did
look at what could we do without the
network and we did see a signal with
patient-specific and did not see a
signal with non patient-specific
approach so we do is something there is
something there but definitely you can /
tube the network that would be a great
way of also taking validating this and
in this perspective this is also why we
chose the hippy network because it's
weighted according to how many different
experiments so the same interaction so
it's sound what more reliable but again
you're raising a very important point
definitely so your crucible these
vacations pictures or our
so you also have this is healthy
patients in comparison before you defuse
with the healthy patients we don't have
healthy patients we stimulate a healthy
healthy patient so we need to start from
somewhere right we need a prior set we
choose Cain random note nodes in the
network where k is the number of
mutations that the patient head and then
we repeat this a thousand times so we
just choose random starting points and
then we get the distribution question so
in this case you look on the ad genes
for which you have drugs which is a
summation point which kinds of other the
focus your attention to what
intervention may helps but in principle
if you could target energy so sometimes
you say I'm a target this one we do it
isn't there a risk that you could then
target the genes that are actually
responsive and have actually buffering
the disease and kill those guys rather
the ones that are really losing the
disease so you're asking whether we may
look at the genes that are downstream of
the other data also some immune response
genes are the subjects that response to
the perturbation to control value it and
you really don't want to bring them down
you want to bring the causative table
now not the one which buffer problem
yes definitely so we are worried of side
effects or peripheral side effects and
this is again this is again a question
of how much you want to be specific you
want to change only these genes and not
others right so in this approach you
could insert this very easily so just
not wanting to push them but here is a
question so that's part of it that want
to change this one not the other but
what I'm asking sometimes is I do really
want to change those well that's in
change because they may be big landscape
of the genomic expression change and
maybe some of them are benefit to bring
down to what normal was second maybe you
don't want to come to change the
expression of some also change the
entire signature rewards the NP right
there for you no need for the ones
though the bed right if you have auto
signature okay yeah that again so